Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
Mi nombre es Luis Muñoz y estamos en una
entrevista especial desde la Feria
Internacional del Libro de Bogotá en
este están nuestra casa durante la feria
de France 24 donde nos ha venido a
visitar Juan villoro escritor mexicano y
uno de los grandes nombres de la
literatura en español en el momento
Gracias Juan por estar acá Gracias a ti
Luis acaba de publicar la figura del
mundo que tenemos acá de la editorial
Penguin Random House un texto cuyo
centro es su padre Luis villoro un
filósofo catalano mexicano y quería
preguntarles si ese planteamiento que
hace al principio de si los
intelectuales deberían tener hijos Si ha
encontrado la respuesta después de
escribir el libro bueno es una situación
compleja la de los padres que se dedican
al pensamiento o al arte y deciden tener
hijos porque Generalmente son padres que
quieren estar en otra realidad no
quieren estar en esta quieren estar
regulando quieren estar componiendo
melodías quieren estar haciendo pintura
y de momento se olvidan de la gente que
les está dando lata que es la gente con
la que viven entre otras cosas los hijos
en general los artistas los
intelectuales han sido malos padres y yo
le robé el título a Michelle turnier el
gran escritor francés porque él escribió
sobre klausman el hijo de Thomas su
padre el mejor novelista de Alemania el
más exitoso Premio Nobel todo giraba en
la casa en torno al escritorio del padre
y él también era novelista Entonces el
hijo escribió una novela espléndida
mefisto pero se sintió siempre
inadaptado incapaz de hacer las paces
con esa figura y acabó suicidándose por
otras razones también pero bueno la
situación es que no es fácil estar con
alguien que se encuentra desajustado
respecto al mundo y escribir sobre un
padre que se dedicó a la filosofía que
es una labor profundamente abstracta
pues es también
un intento de cercanía la literatura
trabaja con emociones yo sabía que mi
padre me iba a respetar a mí si yo
escribía un libro porque lo que más le
gustaba en el mundo eran los libros pero
el libro que yo decidí escribir desde el
primero Hasta ahora es un libro que
tiene que ver con con la pasión con la
emoción con los arrebatos de los que
trata la literatura entonces Este es un
camino emocional hacia un padre racional
y creo que a mí me ha servido al menos
así lo quiero ver como un proceso de
sanación es decir No sé si todo mundo
debe tener hijos hay intelectuales que
han sido maravillosos padres Por ejemplo
yo conozco a los hijos de García Márquez
que el padre los adoraba ellos los
adoraban etcétera ahí hay éxitos
afectivos dentro de las familias pero
este es un camino personal de
entendimiento y de construcción de
sentido del padre que yo tuve usted
habla precisamente de Cien años de
soledad bueno de Gabriel García Márquez
quería preguntarle si un libro de la
magnitud de Cien años de soledad es hoy
posible de escribir en un mundo en el
que hay paternidades presentes
responsabilidades domésticas pago de
facturas bueno cada época encuentra la
manera de expresar la complejidad del
mundo Yo creo que la literatura
demuestra una y otra vez que lo que
nosotros no considerábamos que podía ser
posible de pronto tiene una manera de
expresarse entonces es posible que un
libro como la Cien años de soledad que
es como Las mil y una noches una saga
gigantesca de historias la estirpe de
una familia evidentemente no se no tiene
sentido escribir algo igual pero hay
muchas maneras de abordar la literatura
Y quizá esa Aventura extraordinaria del
ser humano se exprese de otro modo
pensemos por ejemplo en la odisea la
odisea es si se mira la historia de un
hombre que quiere volver a su casa es un
problema doméstico es un problema
contemporáneo escrito en en la época de
los rapsodas por esa figura que llamamos
Homero y que probablemente es un
colectivo de personas el viaje verdad de
odiseo y luego llamado Ulises por los
latinos es un viaje mitológico es un
viaje épico pero en la modernidad James
Joyce convierte ese viaje en regresar a
casa en dublín es decir que hay muchos
modos y muchas maneras de enfrentarse a
los predicamentos que el ser humano
tiene siempre entonces yo yo confío en
la energía de la literatura para que nos
siga sorprendiendo de muchas maneras
volviendo a la novela su padre estuvo
durante toda su vida muy comprometido
con la ejemplaridad el otro día usted
tiene una charla con Martín caparrós y
otros en un momento dijo somos aquí
cinco hombres blancos hablando le dejó
ese legado también de la ejemplaridad me
gustaría pensar que sí mi padre
participó en muchas luchas sociales
entonces la figura del mundo es no
solamente El retrato de una relación
familiar con una persona específica sino
también es un cuadro de Conjunto yo
quería hablar de las luchas sociales de
América Latina mi padre
participó en el movimiento estudiantil
de 1968 él estuvo a punto de ir a dar a
la cárcel fue fundador de varios
partidos políticos de la izquierda
mexicana participó en luchas
latinoamericanas
antiimperialistas y finalmente terminó
su vida convertido en asesor del
movimiento zapatista entonces todo este
arco de vida de alguna manera lo quería
yo reflejar y en cierta forma me ha
marcado a mí mi padre está
enterrado en el caracol de oventic que
es Zona zapatista y ahí se le rindieron
los últimos honores porque los menos
favorecidos de México encontraron a él
en él a un interlocutor válido lo cual
fue Muy conmovedor y es precisamente
zapatismo está muy presente en el libro
es el lema de un mundo donde quepa
muchos mundos es la el lema que puede
abanderar hoy la izquierda también en
esa lucha contra el ese pasado
ultraconservador que también se trata de
despertar desgraciadamente hay ca que se
pretenden de izquierda que cuando llegan
al poder tienen una postura autoritaria
unipersonal y no incluyente el
movimiento zapatista por el contrario es
una aventura de la inclusión es la idea
de que se construya en efecto un mundo
absolutamente plural y ellos han dado
muchos pasos para que esto ocurra
desgraciadamente Los acuerdos que
firmaron con el gobierno mexicano no han
entrado en vigor en el libro yo eh
refiero
a un texto que escribió el subcomandante
Marcos sobre mi padre en el que él
confiesa la forma en que un filósofo se
incorporó clandestinamente al Movimiento
Político de los zapatistas ellos
necesitaban de esa reflexión y y mi
padre se convirtió en en un zapatista
más y eso me parece que es
extraordinario porque concluyó su vida
cerrando un ciclo importante él nació en
Barcelona y llegó a México y y cuando
vio el país por primera vez le pareció
un país corrupto le pareció desigual
violento no se sintió bien y buscó algo
que lo reconfortara y lo encontró en el
México profundo fue de los primeros en
hablar de esta categoría el México
profundo que no solamente se refería al
pasado prehispánico que había dejado las
pirámides y los tesoros que están en los
museos sino al presente o sea entendió
que el México profundo tenía actualidad
y escribió un primer libro a los 30 años
que se llama los grandes momentos del
indigenismo en México que es un libro
sobre los intérpretes de los indios los
mediadores hacia los indios por ejemplo
Fray Bartolomé de las casas pero la vida
le dio la oportunidad de terminar
también el convertido en un Fray
Bartolomé de las casas en un intérprete
directo de los indios en un asesor de
ellos Entonces este arco de vida es el
que cuento en la figura del mundo
paternidad zapatismo también de exilio
identidad la construcción de una
identidad de dónde eres mi papá se
esforzó por ser mexicano y en un momento
les digo usted quiere la partida de
nacimiento para la nacionalidad Española
y le dice eres consciente de cuánto nos
ha costado ser mexicanos yo le quería
preguntar cuánto Les costó ser mexicano
a mí nada Yo soy fatalmente mexicano no
tengo más remedio es lo que soy y no
tengo ningún problema pero mi padre
consiguió la nacionalidad con esfuerzo
primero no le gustó el país y luego
aprendió amarlo y los actos de amor
entrañan También esfuerzo Muchas veces
pensamos que el amor es un impulso
gratuito que nos lleva simplemente a
querer algo muchas veces Hay que
esforzarse por quererlo y Hay que
esforzarse más por conservarlo Entonces
yo aprecio mucho a las gentes que
voluntariamente han tenido una identidad
que no les correspondía y que han
construido una pasión para defender esta
identidad y fue el caso de mi padre con
la identidad mexicana también una forma
de unión para usted con su padre fue el
fútbol en el libro cuenta que uno de los
momentos en el que fue consciente usted
de la muerte de su padre fue cuando le
llegó como un mail del Fútbol Club
Barcelona despidiendo a su padre que es
el Barça también para los villoro el
primer regalo que yo recibí en mi vida
fue un llavero del Fútbol Club Barcelona
y para mí se convirtió en un equipo
fantasmagórico porque entonces no
podíamos ver partidos por televisión del
equipo blaugrana mi papá me decía que
era el mejor equipo del mundo los
parientes de España nos mandaban
recortes de lo que había hecho el
Barcelona etcétera y lo vi jugar en 1962
en una gira en la que fue a México y
luego cuando fui con mi padre por
primera vez España fuimos al Camp Nou a
un derbi Real Madrid Barcelona que
terminó tres a tres en la época de
Charlie reysack una época maravillosa
del del Barça pero que todavía no era el
gran Barça que comenzó con Johan cruyff
entonces para mí el barcelonismo pues es
también esa patria perdida de mi padre
nadie ama tanto la Tierra del origen
Como quien no la tiene y mi padre
nostálgicamente se aferraba al Barcelona
y mi gusto por el fútbol tiene que ver
también con esa pasión identitaria de
conservar algo de su patria perdida en
el exilio por eso cuando él murió Yo soy
el primogénito me tuve que hacer cargo
del funeral estaba demasiado ocupado
atendiendo a la gente y yo no pude
llorar en el funeral porque estaba
demasiado tenso con tantas cosas regresé
a la casa y encontré un fax que me
mandaba El Fútbol Club Barcelona y me
dio mucho gusto que reconocieran la
pasión que yo había tratado de expresar
en muchos escritos por el equipo
blaugrana pero sobre todo me hizo pensar
en la persona que me había llevado por
primera vez a los estadios y que me
había dado esa identidad imaginaria esa
ese sentido de pertenencia que solamente
puede tener un equipo que es más que un
club quería hacerle una última pregunta
muy breve en el entre las muchas
reflexiones del libro usted habla de la
felicidad dice que nadie está contento
por decreto y que Hay que esforzarse
para ser feliz Cuál es ese secreto para
Juan villoro y si hay ingredientes de
Luis villoro bueno la felicidad es una
gramática tenemos que conjugarla tenemos
que ejercerla no no es algo que nos
llegue del cielo y digamos hoy estoy
feliz porque
me gané la lotería no nos ganamos la
lotería todos los días El mundo es
difícil El mundo es una imposición
adversa y tenemos que construir algo
para ser felices uno de los mejores
remedios para melancólicos es la
literatura es una manera de ser feliz en
un mundo que nos queda de ver y sobre
todo la literatura y esa es una paradoja
extraordinaria nos permite ser felices
hablando de tristezas Muchas gracias
Juan por venir a esta casa de France 24
en la filbo Al contrario gracias a
ustedes pueden seguir más contenidos
como este en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]